welcome back to pj chain design we are
going to
finish up the rest of the part with the
stone setting and
completed this milligram design are you
ready let's get started
all right so we're gonna finish up this
ring if you haven't watched the first
part i will have the right top corner so
you can take a look at first so you will
know how we're getting into this part
last video we were talking about how to
do the calculation so it will flow
nicely and there's no gap in between for
the accurate calculation
the second part we are going to finish
up the ring
and for the stone setting so i'm going
to
select my curve and simply just creating
another layer
and send them into uh change the object
to that layer so it's not bothering us
with all the
work that we have done let's simply
just select everybody beside this curve
because we already have that surface and
let's join everybody together
and we are going to do is the sweep one
rail
this is a rail this is the cross section
and we'll finish this ring over here
let me turn it into a different color so
it's easier for you to see
once we open this back all right now
with this one double make sure that
everything is
touching you actually have an intersect
this part into the green part that's
good
and let's join those back together so it
will be
a solid and once again let me turn it
into the green color
all right so if everything look good
it's all
intersect really well and you will have
no problem to the bowling
let's take a look on the stone setting
for the stone setting you can download
the stone for this demonstration i will
have the link at the description below
or if you like to learn how to making a
diamond
i will have the video link on the right
top corner so you can take a look how to
make your own diamond
so i bring in a stone by importing the
model and i'm going to bring this one
up so we can see from the top view at
the top view i simply just going to
scale it down
and to take a look on that if i can
fitting into the space with
all those uh shape so i'm going to come
in
here and make sure they were fitting
into the diamond shape
without cutting too much into the metal
so that's a line
really nice over here so this will be
the size i'm working on maybe just a
little bit bigger
all right so once we have that i'm going
to turn off everything else so it's
easier for us to see to to make in this
stone
first of all i'm gonna coming over to
the right view and i'm going to draw
a bar straight down like this and this
is going to be
our beads all the prong and i'm going to
simply pipe it
so i'm going to make it a little bit
fatter
just because i want to make sure that
the casting will come up really nice
and we are going to moving this one
up you don't want to cut it into the
stone too much
it's roughly about 20 30 percent and
then i'm going to mirror to the other
side
to be something like this okay and
double make sure we want to turn on
um this over here and to make sure that
we will have
the prong is actually touching the frame
so that way we will have
a good contact for the casting all right
and then next things i wanted to do it's
creating the sitting for the stone to
sit
in there so in this case i'm going to
draw a rectangle
and just moving the rectangle in a
little bit and simply
i'm going to go for the revolve for 360
degree and then i will get the box over
there
underneath it now there's a lot of the
stone setting concept
i don't have the time to explain every
detail in this video but
i have a stone setting course if you are
interesting that you can check out that
course that teach you all different kind
of a stone setting
including the fancy cut now let me go
ahead to
temporary to group it just in case we
might need to change
things and i want to turn on my design
over here
let's try it to make it lower by
bringing down like this
and see how they fit in there of course
this one will need to have the
angle but before i just doing the angle
i also want to pick up this uh this set
and i want to making a copy by ctrl c
and ctrl v and bring that one back to
the center
of my ring and just in case i need to do
some adjustment
and then so for this one i'm going to
move it up just a little bit
you always want to have the girdle
sitting on the surface
so that will look much better and maybe
sitting in like that
double make sure it is still right in
the center so i'm going to
simply just move it down a little bit
so visually it's looking right at the
center and you kind of notice that my
prong
is higher than it's supposed to be is
because
you do need a little bit extra for the
jeweler to set
and they will finish and to have the
prong
lower all right so in this one i'm going
to turn in 90 degree
and bringing up the same height with the
first one that i have
and what i like to do is using the
rotation tool and i want to move it to
this place over here there you can
adjust it
the where the location is if you want to
make sure it
it is really accurate you actually want
to
using the rotate tool instead of just
move
for the other one i'm actually going to
use
my rotate tool again and snapping into
this one this time i want to make a copy
and make sure this one is in the right
place
and all we need to do is bring this one
down
a little bit so that way we'll see in
the place right
if it is not in the right place you can
always
using the rotate tool snapping into the
center
and try to bring it back a little bit
this
setting and this setting over here all
we need to do
on that one is to mirror to the other
side
by snapping into the zero so that way
that will fit in there
for this one i cannot mirror it because
that won't be accurate
i actually need to rotate it center is
zero here
and copy equal yes and we are going to
go
from here to here and double make sure
that if it is in the right place it
looks like i need to do
a minor adjustment because the prongs
stick it more on this side
so again i'm going to use a rotate tool
and make sure copy is equal now now
and we are going to just move it back a
little
so it look even so now the stone is
sitting in the right place
i'm going to pick up all the stone right
here
and remember we were doing about uh
seven
sections so i'm gonna going to do the
same with the
polar array snapping into the zero
and the number of items is seven so we
can have all the stone setting into the
right place
and let's turn it back to the ring so we
will have something like that for the
side of the b
setting i have a lot of video talking
about this b
setting in the row and you can check out
the whole playlist for the b
setting i also have a course for the
stone setting class that will teach you
in the detail how to arrange those speed
if you are interested in the course
please check out my website
and that will be our minigrand b
setting band here i hope you enjoyed the
video please
like and comment and let me know how you
like it thanks for watching
and i'll see you next
[Music]
you